although what I'm seeing just doesn't
make sense in any level because you've
got an empty car that we stopped on the
track and an occupied train that somehow
collided with it and this isn't making
sense to me on two levels so I've got
two questions first is how did that
first train come to be stopped on the
track and the second question is how did
the second train clear the lift hill
because there's a there's a block safety
system that should prevent all
collisions on a rollercoaster so if the
first train was saddled in the batwing
as they call it how did the second train
clear the lifts hill something that
there's two different levels of
questions that I have here fundamentally
say one carriage shouldn't be allowed to
go forward with the safety system if
there's already something else on the
track just like with your common
railroad no two trains are allowed to
occupy the same track at any one time so
it suggests possible human error here I
you know I've got to tell you I mean the
first train the empty train being
saddled in that batwing doesn't surprise
me that much okay it's happened on that
ride before and it happens on other
rollercoasters generally the first time
you run it after you've rebuilt the
whole thing and it has fresh grease in
the wheels maybe it's cold out because
it's early in the season and the grease
is real thick and it slows the whole
thing down and it doesn't quite make it
and it comes back okay great you get a
crane you either disassemble it or you
pull it through or whatever but how is
there another train on the track with
people on it that's what I don't
understand at this point and